two years ago at Ted I had the great joy
of interviewing Elon Musk who by common
consent is is probably the world's most
remarkable entrepreneur right now the
world's most remarkable living
entrepreneur what he's done in terms of
the space industry the future of
electric cars future of solar power
truly remarkable and then side projects
like Hyperloop and so forth I are steel
on what what his secret was and he first
refused to answer because they I think
he almost there's a modesty there and
part of him actually genuinely doesn't
know again it's the curse of knowledge
he's he's Elon he doesn't know why
everyone else is different
but one pushed what he said was you
start with physics you know you take
physics seriously so this is a guy who
who is so confident in the efficacy of
science that he will risk his entire
fortune on the belief that he can he can
build a business that taps into the
power of that physics so with SpaceX
without having a winning design for a
rocket he starts this company invest
tens of millions of dollars believing
that physics demands that the cost of
sending stuff up into orbit has to be a
lot lower than NASA was currently paying
it had to be because NASA was paying
ninety nine times the cost of the actual
ingredients or being sent to space that
confidence is just amazing to me and the
fact that he can go from there to
building out and mapping out in his mind
a very complicated future that
incorporates elements of engineering of
physics of business of human psychology
of consumer demand weave it together and
confidently go forward in a particular
direction that's that's amazing that's
there are very few minds that can do it
that way so he's certainly someone I
have
of respectful